councillor thomas
do you want to take a table because
we're going to go back to a gender item
number one
and then we'll come yeah thank you
uh good evening everybody thank you for
waiting thank you for attending tonight
this is a meeting of the planning and
development management committee of
trafford council my name is councillor
ben hartley and i'm the chair of the
committee the vice chair is counsellor
barry winstandler who sends us apologies
this evening
down the two sides of the table are
members of the planning committee who
are all local councillors
and on my immediate left and right are
officers advising the committee from the
planning team the highways team and the
legal team from the council this meeting
is being uh live stream now we're in
public session so the meeting is being
uh recorded and and streamed on the
council's youtube channel
start with item one agenda which is
attendances
and any apologies for absence we've had
uh apologies from councillor win stanley
as i mentioned and
grateful to councillor o'brien for
attending as a substitute and we've had
apologies from cancel at dagnall as well
and i'm grateful to councillor maitland
for
uh stepping in as a substitute
we have also had apologies i believe
from councillor morgan but i don't think
we've got a substitute member for
councilman morgan no thank you
and
everybody else is present i think so
we'll move on to item number two
declarations of interest which is
members to give notice of any personal
or prejudicial interest in the nature of
the interest
relating to any item on the agenda in
accordance with the
adopted code of conduct uh any members
looking to declare interest councillor
chalking
thanks just to declare a prejudicial
interest in claredon house so i'll be
stepping out to that one
thank you councillor chalking
uh councillor thomas
yeah i've called um
i've called i'ma call him for uh 3a
marlborough road as ward councillor
thank you council thomas uh i have an
interest to declare as well which
relates to
um 12 park avenue in sale
uh i've consulted with the with the
applicant a number of times and i'll be
speaking in favor of that application
uh our vice chair councillor winston
isn't here so i've spoken to councillor
walsh and would propose that councillor
walls chairs that item which i think
he's happy with uh members of the
committee content with that for the item
okay thank you everyone thank you
councillor walsh
we move on to minutes now
of the last meeting so it's to receive
and if so determined to approve
as a correct record the minutes of the
meeting uh held on 14th july 2022
um our members content with those
minutes and i'm hoping it comes to
thomas happy to move and i'm seeing nods
yeah councillor proctor happy to second
so
we'll approve those minutes as a correct
record of the last meeting
item number four is questions from
members of the public so a maximum of 15
minutes will be allocated to public
questions
submitting him writing to democratic
services by 4 pm on the working day
prior to the meeting questions must be
within the unit of the committee or be
relevant to items appearing on the
agenda and will be submitted in the
order in which they were received
we did have a question from a member of
the public but it related to the item
on clarendon house in altringham
and it was an observation about the the
applicant in the application and i
believe that's been picked up in the
additional information report so i don't
think we need to read out the question
and provide an answer no we can put it
up as part of the item
okay moving on to item five the
additional information report members
will have seen that i know so we'll
consider
that report as we as we look at each of
the applications for permission to
develop so we'll move on now to item
number six applications for permission
to develop and we've obviously
considered the reports um we're going to
deal with the applications in a
different order to that they are listed
in
and we're going to start with
application 107 960 which is 3a
marble road in uh in flixton
uh councillor thomas if you wouldn't
mind stepping away because obviously not
sitting on on this item thank you
and for members of the committee the um
papers for this start on page 105 of the
bundle and we'll start with a
presentation from miss lowe's thank you
thank you chair
and this application relates to a
retrospective application for a detached
two and a half story dwelling
um at 3a marlborough road
the application site comprises land
which originally formed part of through
marlborough road and its side garden
area
prior to the works commencing on site
there was a large detached double garage
and single-story side extension
on this part of the site which have
since been demolished
retrospective permission is sought for a
six-bedroom detached dwelling with
living accommodation over three floors
including
in the roof space
planning permission was granted for a
four-bedroom two-story dwelling
in january 2015. this permission has
expired and is no longer extent the
scheme under consideration in within
this application
um differs from that approved scheme
and on the slides now you can see the
elevations of the development has built
the front elevation and the side
elevation
again the other side and the rear
elevation
you can see the um half mansard roof
and creating the additional floor
and the um part rendered part brick
built building
the next set of slides will show the
building as built compared to the
building as approved within the 2015
permission so on the left hand side
you can see there's built
development and on the right-hand side
you can see the development
as approved you can see the difference
in the roof form and the difference in
the fenestration detailing and a canted
bay on the front
and
the window and the window proportions
and and style
again um on this elevation on this slide
you have the rear again as built on the
left hand side and as approved on the
right hand side again you can see the
difference in the roof and slight
difference in the ground floor
projection
and on the as approved
scheme
i just flick through these these are the
thus the side elevations you can see the
comparison between the two in terms of
the roof form
and again on the opposite side
and you can see the detail and it's
slightly different in terms of the the
fenestration and the detailing
the principle of additional housing in
an urban area is supported by the core
strategy however the policies set out
that they should reflect the local
character of the area the officer report
identifies local characteristics and
analyzes the development against these
the
the design of the dwelling in
particularly the roof form does not
reflect the local character and local
distinctiveness
officers conclude that it appears
visually intrusive and in congress
within the street scene harmful to
character and parents
and
this adverse impact would carry very
substantial weight
there are some benefits of the scheme
through the provision of an additional
dwelling however this contribution
is negligible to housing supply and this
limits the overall benefit
overall the adverse impacts of the
development would significantly and
demonstrably outweigh the benefits
there is conflict with up-to-date
adopted development plan and the mppf
and the application is therefore
recommended for
free for refusal
i'll just go back to the photographs
that we're up on the slides so um
members can see the as built development
you may have visited the site and seen
and the development has built and but
you can see from across the road
um the development adjacent to the
original property number three
and from the side there
thank you
thank you mrs we have uh no speakers
against this item and we have two
speakers for uh
is emma jones with us this evening yeah
so uh we'll hear from you first miss
jones and councillor thomas i know you
want to speak on the item um
so mr jones just make sure the
microphone is on in front of you just
press that button and yeah if you just
make sure you're close to the microphone
yeah it is
uh yeah just stay close to the
microphone so that we can pick up what
you say
uh you'll have three minutes to speak to
us
we'll start timer once you start talking
and uh if you've not finished after
three minutes i'll just ask you to begin
to wrap up your remarks okay thank you
[Music]
good evening all the relevant background
to this retrospective application is
that planning permission was originally
granted for a house on the site in 2015.
the applicant mr ralph later sought to
amend those proposals and reasonably
believing he had the relevant permission
progressed on site in spring
2021 until ceasing development in
october after being advised by trafford
planning enforcement that there was in
fact no planning permission in place
this draft genuinely believed that you
had planning permission for the house
that you started building and there's
been no deliberate attempt to build a
property that is not acceptable in
design terms or non-compliant in any way
the house that has been built is
essentially as per the approved plans as
it is to the same footprint and the
variations to the design have been made
in keeping with other properties in the
street scene the design is not highly
incongruous as stated in the committee
report rather the changes from the
approved house are relatively minor and
do not cause material harm to the
character of the area
the key difference between the approved
plans and the amended plans is the
design of the roof whilst officers
originally saw a hip roof design
presumably to match that of number three
it's relevant to note that there's
actually a much wider range of reforms
in the surrounding area and most typical
nearby roofs are those with gable ends
also the adjacent property number 7a
easdale close built by mr ralph with no
issues has a very similar mantad style
roof profile
the
the introduction therefore of the gable
end is entirely in keeping with the
street scene the mansard style roof
reaches a shallow pitch roof with an
apex from most viewpoints as highlighted
by photographs submitted and can be
easily seen on site
the house is not as visible or prominent
in the street scene as it is purported
to be in the committee report from the
north there are only limited views of
the house as it is set back from the
corner
and screened by mature street trees the
small flat roof element of the mansard
roof is not visible really from the
north at all from the south it is
situated at the end of a row of
two-story properties and there's a
similarly proportioned uh property it
doesn't appear out of character once the
rendering is completed the property will
be in keepings of the properties found
in the area
another difference in the design from
the approved plans is the deletion of
the bay from the frontage
this difference is in keeping with the
flat fronted bungalows to the north of
the site and due to the views i've
already described is not in any case
particularly noticeable in the street
scene by its emission however there is a
potential for greater articulation to be
reintroduced to the frontage if this is
a concern for members
through for example the addition of a
porch officers have not discussed
potential amendments to make the design
of the property acceptable and mr ralph
is more than willing to make reasonable
changes such as the inclusion of a porch
and make except and will accept
conditions relating to the landscape and
the access
um we therefore ask that members approve
this application contrary to the
officer's recommendation thank you thank
you miss jones thanks for coming to
speak to us uh councillor thomas do you
want to
take a seat um
you'll know that you have five minutes
to speak to us and we'll start the timer
once you start talking thank you
thank you i'd like to explain why i
think that this decision is incorrect
and that's that is granted for
granted by the committee
the main and in fact the only reason for
refusal is it does not fit in with the
street scene and in the officer's
opinion
is visually intrusive and in congress to
the street scene
marvel road has a varied style of
building from more side road to windsor
avenue incorporating some 1930s style
semi detached and three-bedroom and
detached properties with some older
properties including uh i think number
three and five
therefore the street scene is not a
single conforming style but includes
some individual individuality parts of
the road though in an effort to make
this development akin to the immediate
locality first floor rendering which is
not in place
is due to continue if planning
permission is granted
and mr ralph actually stopped because
compliance told him that he didn't have
any planning permission so he ceased
building immediately as the council
asked him
this will make the rendering make it
similar to
number three and number five meaning
that war passing walkers cyclists and
motorists would know the similarity
rather than any differences to the
property
it's also negated because the property
is set back from the roads from eight to
ten meters allowing provision for three
car parking spaces and landscaping to
the front of the property
the application is also to include three
similar parking spaces to number three
alleviating the
concern of parking spaces and park on
the road
uh at number three marlborough road this
was included in the original application
that was passed in 2015
and thought to be incorrectly however uh
continued forward in this
application the application applicant is
happy to accept this being placed as a
condition on the property likewise the
introduction of three trees landscaping
to the rear is also an application these
reasonable to the build
the roof with the mansard design in
gable end is another objection from the
from the officer as in congress and yet
directly across the road the houses at
number four down to number 20 all have
gable end style roof roofs
as as does number seven
the semi touch three and number five are
the only properties on that side of the
street on both sides of the street to
winter avenue that have a hip roof of
any kind with no cable end
the reference to the man style mozart
style roof sorry
uh
being detrimental as you saw from the
photographs from the front of the house
you can't even tell it's a man's side as
you're looking at the property and when
you look from the top of my side of my
side road downwards you can't see
because of the foliage and the trees
there are that dense that you still
would not notice the mountside roof from
that side of the property as alluded by
the agent
the amount of the cable end is hidden
by number three and number five to a
great extent
mention of the pitch in the roof
is being excessively steep it's also
incorrect as the pitch is 38.5 degrees
well within the 30 to 50 degrees
determined and acceptable as for the
impact on the character of the area 7a
eastdale was built by mr alf
the original plans were for a rich style
roof and six months into
those plans he applied through the
council to a change uh to include the
massage roof which the council passed
um mr ralph did not has demonstrated his
deliberations in meeting planner
requirements and this did not go ahead
until the planning permission for the
mansard was given
the mentioning report regarding the
previous applications have no bearing on
this application however retrospective
this application is
building controls also have no bearing
on this application but for clarity
though the office are aware of the
issues by mentioning in the report mr
ralph has not yet been given those
breaches and he is happy to discuss that
with trafford's building regulations uh
come their team as they are part of the
team that he's employed
to finish the development of this is
provision of two families mr ralph and
his son and daughter-in-law and their
three children
that in itself will fill two further
properties where his son is renting and
number three marlborough down mr ralph
lives already this is going to become a
family home and mr ralph has sought to
meet officers to have discussions as yet
that has not come to fruition
i ask therefore that this application is
granted
thank you councillor thomas um
i'll look to members of the committee in
a moment i just want to miss those i
could just ask you to
proud to provide some advice on on two
things which the speakers mentioned one
was the
concern around parking for number three
so when our councilor thomas mentioned
that
parking for three cars i think could be
accommodated at number three and the
report raised that as a concern
and then the other issue which i think
both speakers mentioned was around the
the roof form
and the
um the reference to the bay being a
number of similar roofs in the area
similar mansion roofs in the area and
the relevance of that thank you
yes of course um in terms of the parking
i think in the report whilst we um note
that there is a lack of parking for
number three marlborough we recognize
that that an amended plan could be
provided to demonstrate this um and that
we would in a in an event where an
application was acceptable we would
condition that
so that's fine in terms of the roof
forms yes again it's noted within the
report that there's varying roof forms
within the wider area if um
paragraph 20 the table below and where
the
with this where we've set out the design
elements of of the local characteristics
and it clearly references that gable
ends or hipped roofs and that rise up to
an apex are a character of the area and
that is noted and obviously number three
does have a a hipped roof and there is a
number of other couple of of properties
that have hit proofs but but equally
officers recognize that there are
gable-ended properties within within the
area as well
and um
and that's that that's noted i think in
the original commission in 2015 and
there was quite a long lengthy
negotiation
in arriving at that approved um
design with the the hipped roof in order
to to mitigate the mass on that corner
it's a corner location and i think
whilst it's not directly visible
and due to the to the dense trees there
are views across
and from more side road to to the
property and there and i think it was
about reducing that that level of mass
on that corner location and and
replicating number three in in that in
that in that in the roof form
thank you thank you miss lowes any
members of the committee looking to
speak on this item please
councillor walsh thanks chair um
i was on google uh this morning and it
happened to have the the house that was
previously on the site
a much smaller house
and i have to say much more in keeping
with with the other houses on
marlboro road i was quite surprised
google must be out today we actually
visited the site um on monday evening
and um
there's no other way of saying it
i i believe the officers have got this
right i do believe it's in in congress
it does not fit in with that street
scene
now that
i said i looked at google and the house
that was there previously was very very
small
this site can take a big house
um
and i don't think i've got any issue
with with the size of the property
but i do think it doesn't fit in and a
bay window
to the front and people might think that
is a minor issue but there is no bay
window and a lots of the other
properties certainly have those
they are small
and can i say some of the modest
semi and detached houses on marlborough
road and this is a this is a big
property
um
you might think that if a bigger
property would wouldn't want to work
harder to fit in
uh with the street scene but this
certainly doesn't
and um
i do have concerns about it and
certainly i will notice i hate what
people said about the cladding and
certainly that will help but the window
frames and the doorway
the lady mentioned the porch i don't
think we're here to discuss what might
and might not be done
i'm not really interested in and how we
got here if this had come to me as a
drawing instead of it's being built the
situation we have
if this has come to me as a drawing
i would genuinely be saying the same
thing i do think it stands out i don't
think it fits in
and there's been mention of the
design consultation with with residents
i i've been to those to one of those in
stratford
and um
we want houses to reflect the character
of the area and this certainly does not
and if and
when we do those consultation is a
consultation
i think um
comment has been made that
these are not set policies this is this
is a proposals and we're consulting with
residents on to come to a document later
um but we wouldn't be saying that this
is typical of the area on marlborough
road or that area of ernst and we
wouldn't certainly wouldn't be saying
and we'd like to see more of this
because i certainly would not like to
see more of that in the area um
i i just i'm i'm trying to uh
be diplomatic i know this is going to be
difficult for the applicant but i really
can't support each other i don't know
what other members think i'm interested
in what they say but i would be moving
refusal chair thank you very much
thank you councillor walsh uh councillor
chalking
uh thank you sir um i'll keep it fairly
brief i i
agree with what council of wales has
just said is i drove down the road i
didn't spend
a great deal of time at the site because
i saw straight away that it stuck out
like a sore thumb um i i do agree with
the officers and that it isn't in
keeping with what's there and we have um
i've got in front of me here the the
report that was sent to members
from the uh town planning uh on behalf
of the applicant and photo four was to
me and no members can't see it and
stopped me from speaking afterturn but
it's quite clear that it stands out it
doesn't fit the house next door the roof
is the wrong angle the wrong pitch sorry
and all and all they
agree with the comment about window even
putting some of them will make it
slightly better but
for me it doesn't it's not in keeping
with the area it it it does stick out
and
i do agree with officers report so i'm
happy to
propose we accept their
uh recommendations
thank you council chalking uh councillor
bunting
thank you chairman um
the risk of sounding like a stock record
uh i'm going to agree with both of the
two previous two speakers
um you are going to there's no way
you're not gonna i know uh it has been
suggested that because of the foliage in
the area of the other housing
surrounding it you're not going to
notice this
um
where you are you very obviously are um
it does look out of character but in
terms of i know the council has been
some slight differences with the windows
i think every single one of them is
different
and the win on the roof is radically
different
um and uh
i would agree with the officer
conclusion it's somewhat essentially the
office of conclusion that the previous
one was was acceptable because there was
application going for it the second one
is not
um
again as council walsh uh said quite
correctly how we ended up in this
position is not the relevant factor at
this stage
uh the point is even if there was no
change from the existing building that
was there originally and they came to us
and said this is what we'd like to do i
would i would have the same concerns as
council walsh has already stated so i
agree uh agree wholeheartedly with him
on that
um i can't continue but
council wish you didn't make a proposal
you did at the council so in that case
it's been seconded so there's no need
for me to uh second anything so i will
simply say that i'll be voting uh in
line with office organization as my two
colleagues have stated they will be also
thank you jeremy thank you council
bunting cancer i can owler
could have just asked what would
actually happen if it was refused
if it was refused it would then be
passed to the planning compliance team
who would review it in terms of the
relevant enforcement action
uh councillor mate
and now i've got to disagree with
everybody i'm sorry i don't think it
looks that bad at all um
it looks like a bill that there it's
it's something that's being built at the
moment and i'm thinking yeah once it
gets the um
the cladding or whatever they put on
it'll look like the others i know it's
not got the bay window went to the side
yes that's an unusual roof um but then i
look down the road and there's a
bungalow with exactly the same shaped
roof
um on is it
eastdale
just behind the back garden there's a
bungalow there and it's got the same
type of flat bit on the top sorry i
don't know the technical terms for it
um
and i really didn't think it looked that
bad
what i have noticed that there doesn't
seem to be any representations against
this from residents
so that's my bit sorry
thank you councillor maitland uh any
other members
looking to speak on this item no
so it's been moved and seconded that we
uh that we refuse uh permission as per
the officer's recommendation
so we will vote on that motion now so
all those in favor of
refusing permission as per officer
recommendation if you could indicate no
please
and all those against that motion please
okay so that motion is carried and
permission is refused for the
application so that brings us to the end
of the item
the next
item we'll consider is clarendon house
in altering him application 107.530
and we'll just pause for a moment whilst
some of the speakers leave cancer chalk
in is is leaving us for this item as he
indicated earlier
and we'll just wait for
councillor thomas to
appear
this item starts on uh page one of the
bundle
and we will start with a presentation
from miss lowe's thank you
thank you chair this application relates
to um clarigen house and stanford new
road in altringham and is for the
remodeling and conversion
in associated with some change of use to
provide 68 new dwellings the works
include a two-story upward extension
extensions to the front and rear new
windows cladding balconies alterations
to shop fronts and a new entrance lobby
at ground floor
parking landscaping and associated
infrastructure
the application site is located in
ultraman town centre and comprises the
seven story predominantly brown brook
flat-roofed 1970s building known as
clarendon house the ground floor
contains a number of commercial units
with retail frontages onto stanford new
road and the upper floors are set back
from the lower levels
the previous uses of the building
whereas offices in alteringham library
and the building is attached to number
42 stanford new road station hotel and
this is a grade 2 listed building the
site is not within the conservation area
itself but it lies within the setting of
three conservation areas and a number of
listed buildings
planning permission is sought for the
change of use of clarendon house from
retail
office and a former library to
residential and to provide 68 new
dwellings this would include 31 new
shared ownership units which equates to
45 affordable housing provision
a two-story upward extension is proposed
on the main office building and i'll
just
highlight where that is
here on um you can see on the elevation
here
and that results in a maximum of nine
stories
a further two-story upward extension is
also proposed to the lower format
library elements and that results in
five stories in total
other extensions are to the front of the
building and extending the bays here
and an extension to the rear two bays
wide at fourth and fifth floor levels
in terms of materials some of the
existing brick will be reused but a
significant amount of the existing brick
would be removed and replaced by brick
of a more consistent tone and appearance
this will be complemented by a green
terracotta appearance cladding and works
would also take place to the windows
fenestration details and throughout the
elevational treatments to create a more
consistent appearance
the application is reported to committee
as the council as the landowner and two
representations have been received
during the consideration of the
application
amendments have been made in
respect to the detailing and materials
to increase landscaping and to include
biodiversity enhancements and also to
increase the affordable housing
provision from an initial offer
of six percent up to 45
of which would be 100 shared ownership
due to the increased height of the
building less than substantial harm has
been identified to the surrounding
heritage assets
but the public benefits of the scheme
are considered to outweigh
this harm
the tilted balance is engaged
given the council's lack of five-year
housing land supply and significant
weight is given to the regeneration of
this vacant building on a sustainable
brownfield site
the high quality design of the scheme
the contribution to housing land supply
the provision of affordable housing
contributions towards education and the
overall economic benefits
adverse impacts of the development are
harm to heritage assets the tenure mix
of the of the affordable housing which
doesn't include any social rent and some
minor shortfalls in respect of amenity
space and daylight sunlight
however overall it's concluded that the
proposal would comply with the
development plan when taken as a whole
and that the adverse impacts of the
development do not significantly and
demonstrably outweigh the benefits
this application is recommended for
approval subject to a section 106
agreement and appropriate conditions
thank you
thank you miss
um we don't have any speakers against
this item is miss daniel's with us
come and have a seat at the um chair
opposite me miss daniels and
if you just press the button on the unit
in front of you just so the microphone
is hi
hi and just keep yourself close to the
microphone so we pick up on on what you
say
um you'll have three minutes to speak to
us and we'll start the timer once you
start speaking and if you go up to three
minutes i'll just ask you to wrap up
what you're saying okay thank you no
problem thank you chair good afternoon
councillors my name is katie of unkelly
property solutions and we are here today
to present you the application for
residential development in ultra kim
town centre
on behalf of our client city house i try
not to repeat too much of what your
office is presented here but as set out
in the comprehensive report and the
presentation this afternoon the
application relates to clarendon house
which is an existing seven-story brown
brick building in austrian town centre
which has a number of um retail units at
the ground floor and the upper storeys
are formerly the library and office
spaces and they've now been vacant for
in excess of of seven years
the application seeks the change of use
of this vacant building and one of the
ground floor units
and
all the upper floors
along with the minor ground floor
extensions and a two-story rooftop
extension to form 68 new homes and that
will include a mix of studio one two and
three bedroom apartments as noted
already 31 of the 68 apartments proposed
will be provided as shared ownership
properties and they'll be managed by a
registered provider and they meet the
council's requirement for the 45
provision of affordable housing in this
location
turning to design matters i hope you've
all managed to have a little look at the
plans
at home ahead i just note that the
colors are all a bit skewed on these uh
images here so
i just wanted to point that out
and the scale mattered and design of the
building has been developed in close
liaison with planning and conservation
officers to ensure that the proposals
are of the highest quality and they do
respect both the existing building and
those in close proximity and as
mentioned the surrounding heritage
assets
by way of parking there's 42 existing
parking spaces which will be allocated
for residential parking in the adjoining
car park and these allocated spaces
include electric vehicle charging spaces
family spaces and accessible spaces a
small drop-off area is also provided
within the car park and it's adjacent to
the residential development at the third
floor level
turning to other considerations a number
of technical assessments have been
undertaken during the design evolution
to ensure that the impact of the
development has been appropriately
assessed and where necessary mitigated
and there have been no objections to the
proposals from statutory consultees it's
important to note we've also positively
engaged with the local community holding
a virtual public consultation event
between december 21 and january 22 and
the feedback received from the event was
positive and supportive of the proposals
following the public consulate
consultation event a further meeting was
held with the alternative design panel
to discuss the proposals in more detail
to conclude our client is committed to
the delivery of the development and
they've worked positively with your
officers to bring forward a
well-designed scheme which makes use of
a vacant and underutilized building and
will contribution will contribute to the
council's regeneration aims for the area
with consideration to the quality of the
proposed scheme and the benefits
highlighted i do hope that the committee
is able to support the office's
recommendation and approve the
application today thank you thank you ms
daniels thank you for coming to speak to
us
looking at members of the committee to
start the debate on this item
councillor bunting
thank you chairman i think this is a
quite a good design actually is it as it
happens i mean clowning the houses as is
not exactly
the most beautiful building in trafford
i think it's reasonable to say and this
is
at least i will perhaps give it a maybe
slightly limited compliment of a
significant if
uh less than overwhelming improvements
if that could be as as
if i could construed as a compliment i
think they have actually managed to
do the difficult if not the impossible
very difficult to actually improve the
overall look of that building which is
to be welcomed i mean it's still not
exactly there but you know it's not
exactly gonna
it's not gonna become a thing of beauty
but it is a significant improvement on
that which is there already and i think
it's uh i think the design will sort of
uh this maybe wants its age to do it
more as well blending reasonably well
with with the surrounding area in terms
of the
uh
reuse of this is residential rather than
office i have no objection to that and
uh i can see no other
reasonable or sustainable grounds for
any kind of refusal so on those grounds
chairman with that said i'm more than
happy to propose that which is uh before
us thank you chairman
thank you councillor bunting councillor
thomas
thank you chair um
i think it's a very good application in
in general but i would like to just
point out as uh
as i bang on about it here
the uh
and accessible to all i think that the
designer and
architect should be
congratulated on
such a diverse
layout thank you
sorry how second the
proposal
thank you council thomas councillor
welton
thanks chair um yes as a ward councillor
i do want to um welcome this this
development i mean
how fantastic to
create
such uh
i think it's quite beautiful actually a
design building out of uh what is really
quite ugly at the moment and uh uh i
mean given what you had to work with i
think that designers need to need to be
complemented and i actually think that
this can lead
will actually lead the regeneration of
of stanford new road along there
obviously we do have the work going on
on the rackhams building already
but you know this looking straight out
over across to the station will
you know
as people come out of altrium station if
they're visiting for the first time
this and the consistency as long as the
consistency of design you know across
the shop fronts is you know is adhered
to which hopefully it will be um you
know i think it makes a real statement
that the you know that the altering them
is is not just a market town but is a
you know it's it's about the whole town
centre and i think that's that's really
welcome
it's incredibly sustainable obviously i
mean
there's not many parking spaces but it
don't need to be it's directly opposite
a station and it's great that this isn't
being made a thing of there's no
objections you know i mean
amazing
to have a development like this with no
objections um and obviously the shared
ownership is is is welcome as well um so
yes very very welcome thank you
thank you councillor walton uh
councillor proctor
thank you chair when i read the original
document and it had four affordable
houses i was
utterly outraged
because we have a policy of 40
of any
large-scale developments should be
affordable
i'm absolutely thrilled that they've
seen sense and they've
made more than 40
of the
flats affordable flats and
i'm thrilled to see it thank you
thank you council brother uh councillor
hassan
all right
i'm very pleased
and
fully agreed with my previous
colleagues what they have said about
this
stunning and a beautiful addition to
town center
and
it is not really a beautiful building
but they have covered all the questions
what we normally ask
about the parking and the visitors
parking and the electric charging
and affordable houses and
education as well
so i am very pleased and
to support this application and fully
support the thesis recommendation thank
you
thank you council assad kenza walsh
thanks chair um
just going
members have been talking about um
shared ownership social housing
um
just on the top of page 13 um paragraph
16
uh
we'd normally
seek a 50 50 split between intermediate
and social rented housing
but no objection has been raised because
that's not going to be the case here
could miss lowe's could you just talk
about about that issue
yes i think um the report recognises
that um the scheme is 100 shared
ownership and that there's a harm
arising out of the conflict with the
policy and due to the lack of social
rented units but after consultation with
the um council's housing strategy and
growth manager she recognized that there
was a need in this location for shared
ownership
units and that she wholly supported the
provision of 100 shared ownership um in
in this location
thank you guess what yeah
just on that issue of first homes we're
not providing first homes and
i can't see a reason for that sure there
is one could you speak to that while
we're not providing first home
[Music]
um again um
the first homes is a new policy that's
come in and that there should be 25 of
the the units provided and there was
some difficulties for the applicant in
providing the first homes and they um
set out that they wanted to provide them
as 100 shared ownership again we
recognise that that's the scheme doesn't
comply with the national policy and
there's an adverse impact of that
and that's where you're doing the
planning balance
[Music]
yeah thanks chair um
another speaker and favor talks about
we've been empty for seven years and
clearly
uh we want development to take place i'm
just conscious that we don't want to be
falling into
um
a theme that
we can't have our policies adhered to we
can't have our first homes
we can't have our
social housing
and because the developer needs to get
get the thing built and it needs to be
it needs to pay for itself
you know what we call it the tipped
balance something like that it's always
going to go that way but
those policies are not meaningless first
homes are needed i would love
um a young couple first time buyer to
have the chance of shared ownership
at clarendon house that's clearly not
going to be the case
but but i don't think i think
our policies are there for a reason and
councillors have spoken about
it being an improvement and what was
proposed at first
i just think it could be better um
but uh with that chair
i'll close thank you
thank you chancellor walsh
miss lowe's could you just say a little
bit more about the first homes scheme
and how that differs from
shared ownership i know it's a national
policy that was a pretty recently but
that might help members i think thank
you yes um first homes are a discount
market sales product
so that would be managed by a developer
rather than a registered provider or a
housing association and and those
discount market sales are 30
of the market value and they go would go
to um first-time buyers
thank you um any other members looking
to speak on this item
i mean for my part i i think agree with
what other speakers have said i won't
repeat anything
uh that they have said they only do any
sort of additional things i mean i i
think it's a real credit to officers
actually that
they've negotiated a proportion of
affordable housing which
is at least compliant with local policy
45 given the starting point that we're
at and um
i think we should recognize the work
that goes on to
to get up to those levels of affordable
housing and i think it sends you a
really good message to developers that
you know they need to know we'll stick
to this and we'll push them hard on it
and they do need to provide levels of
affordable housing that are policy
compliant i do share council walsh's
concerns and it's regressible that
they're all shared ownership and that
there's there's no
uh there's no socially rented or
affordable rented uh units as part of
that but
um you know i do take some comfort from
the
um the housing and growth managers
uh input that actually shared ownership
is what's in demand in this particular
location and i think it's useful to have
that input around
specific locations within trafford um
yeah so i i like the scheme i'm quite
excited about it and i'm also in favor
uh any other members looking to add
anything else
[Music]
no okay it's been uh it's been moved and
seconded that we
agree with the officer's recommendation
to grant planning permission um so if we
vote on on that motion now please all
those in favor of granting permission
and that is
unanimous yeah thank you everybody so
that application is uh approved uh as
minded to grant
subject to the section 106 agreement um
so that brings us to the end of that uh
item
council chalking's returning we'll move
on to the next item though but i'm gonna
vacate the chair at this point for
councillor walsh thank you
just bear with me everybody
okay we go to page 12 oh sorry page 56
on your agenda papers we're looking at
12
park avenue and sale and we've got a
presentation for mr day
this application has been reported to
committee as more than six objections
have been received contrary to officer
recommendation
um the application relates to a large
detached victorian property with
accommodation across four floors
including a basement
and converted attic
the property has been operating as a day
nursery since the original planning
commission was granted in 2007
it has a large garden to the rear
and a large detached outbuilding
positioned to the northeast of the main
building
which was granted planning permission in
2008
as a garage with ancillary storage and
workshop
there is hard stunning to the front and
both sides of the building which is used
for parking
the 2007 permission related to the
change of use of the basement and ground
floor only
whilst the upper floors remained in
residential use
the number of children attending the
nursery was
restricted to 20
at any one time with the hours of use
restricted to 0.800 to 1800
permission was
subsequently granted in 2017
for the conversion of the upper floors
to nursery use
with the maximum printed number of
children increased to 38
and the hours of use increased to 0-700
to 1900.
however that permission was not lawfully
implemented
and has now lapsed
the art building has also been converted
to provide an additional classroom
with ancillary kitchen and wc facilities
and a pram and cycle store erected to
the front of the building
these works have been carried out
without planning permission
the current application seeks to
regularize the use of the upper floors
of the main building as nursery
accommodation
the use of the outbuilding as an
ancillary classroom
and the erection of the primary cycle
store
together with an increase in the maximum
number of children to 55
and the hours of use of o700 to 1900
in terms of representations letters of
support have been received from 43
addresses
and objections have been received from
11 addresses together with a petition
with 13 signatures also objecting to the
proposal
the letters of support state there is a
need for the facility in this location
in providing quality child care
the objections raise concerns regarding
increased noise traffic and loss of
immunity
together with a loss of privacy from the
use of the upper floors in the
outbuilding
the principle of the nursery use at the
premises is established the main issues
for consideration therefore relate to
immunity
highway and parking issues resulting
from the use of the upper floors in the
outbuilding
and the increase in the maximum number
of children
the council's nuisance section raises no
objections to the application subject to
conditions
including the implementation of the
supplement of the submitted noise
management plan
and let's consider that subject to
appropriate conditions the proposal
would not have an unacceptable impact
on the immunity of neighboring residents
the lha also raises no objection to the
proposal on highway grounds subject to
conditions
including the implementation of the
submitted travel plan
the proposal is therefore considered to
be acceptable in terms of highway and
parking impacts
the external alterations are also
considered to be acceptable in terms of
design and visual immunity
therefore consider the proposals in
accordance with the development plan and
the application is recommended for
approval
subject to appropriate conditions
thank you chad
thank you mr day um do we have danielle
higgnotes with us
if you'd like to take a seat and switch
your microphone on
you have three minutes
good evening my name is danielle higner
and i'm the owner of poetry montessori
nursery this is coming up to my fifth
year of running per tree montessori
nursery and sale we are committed to
delivering the best care and education
possible and are proud to be voted one
of the top nurseries in sale the nursery
has assisted many local residents over
the years including those who've
supported and objected to this
application we have strong ties with our
community such as the local care home
fiona gardens who we visit regularly we
are also a feeder nursery to part road
primary school and we've facilitated a
pickup service to help parents over the
years with the work commitments
firstly i'd like to address the
objections received regarding noticeable
noise it was noted that the objections
only related to the two years of the
pandemic
we acknowledge this and we apologize for
noise but the reason was simply due to
the whole of our operation being turned
upside down for two years during the
pandemic like most of the world our only
means to keep safe during this time was
to use social distancing in the garden
instructed by the department of
education and public health as a result
we used the garden more than ever for
two years this was coupled with the
neighbours working from home during the
pandemic did not make for a good
combination for noise
in may this year the department of
education and public health allowed
parents back into the nursery and we
were able to go back to normal
operations we now have parents fully
back in the building and we have
followed the new noise plan meticulously
the council's environmental health team
have visited the nursery and have
demonstrated there is no excess noise
secondly i'd like to turn to parking we
have demonstrated there is sufficient
parking spaces to drop children off
morning and evening with no objections
raised by your highways officer
75
of our parents live within walking
distance to our nursery
i believe we are the only nursery in the
whole of trafford who will back a
financial scheme to incentivize parents
to walk to our nursery in fact if it's
successful trafford early years team
have asked us to champion it across the
whole of trafford as a physical
development programme for children as
well as reducing car use and pollution
which i hope this shows how committed we
are improving our neighborhood
also our outdoor classroom was
instrumental during covered and for
people with disabilities
due to it having a staff toilet a
children's toilet a kitchenette on a
ground floor of no steps we have enough
space also for disabled parents or staff
to park if required too
lastly three pre-schools and one nursery
have closed within our immediate area
the early years team clearly point out
there is a deficiency of child care
providers in the sale ashton mersey area
we have witnessed a lot of grandparents
work to collect our children so a nurse
who that is in walking distance is
important for the whole family
as a community we have a responsibility
to look after our children
and most nurseries are within
residential areas and we've seen a rise
in new developments on washway road in
fact the office block at the end of park
avenue has just turned into flats and we
have two inquiries
the increase in the number of our
children at our nursery is key to our
survival and it will be detrimental
should this not be achieved
on behalf of everyone at petrie
montessori nursery including our parents
children and staff we hope this
application is approved tonight and we
can continue what we do best look after
the children of salem ashton mersey area
thank you
thank you very much if you'd like to
return to your seat
any members wishing to speak
oh
the chair one i've gotta let the chair
speak and i think i think there's
another council that wants to speak as
well
[Music]
um thank you again to the world um
i'm speaking in favor of the application
as as one of the world councillors
freshmen on mersey um and i i won't
repeat what miss hignit has said to
already there's some complex planning
history um to the building that's set
out in the report but i think it's
important to note the building has been
used as a day nursery since 2007.
uh miss ignite acquired the nursery as
she mentioned in in 2018
and before buying the uh the nursery she
did engage professional advisors for due
diligence no she was flagged about the
lawful commencement of the planning
permission from 2017
or any failure to discharge planning
conditions so i mentioned that because
of course whilst an applicant can make a
retrospective application for planning
permission i want to sort of stress that
miss ignite reasonably assumed that she
had the benefit of
planning permission for the building for
up to 38 children
there's a large number of comments from
residents which i know members of the
committee will have seen a clear clear
majority of those comments are
supportive of the development it's clear
that there's a demand for nursery places
in the sale area and a lot of the demand
for day nurseries does tend to be very
local
there are objections raised by some of
the residents on two mega two main
grounds the first is is noise
the noise impact assessment uh you'll
have seen and
a noise management plan has recently
been submitted mr signet also referred
to the visit from an environmental
health officer who assessed the uh
the noise
there was a previous complaint about
noise that was closed with no further
action
um so there are
anecdotal complaints about noise from
residents um
but um
it's worth noting that they all
relate to events over the last couple of
years when the way the nursery has been
operating has obviously been different
as you've heard
the actual assessment data from the
noise impact assessment shows no
observed adverse effect
i.e there's no basis for the pollution
and licensing team to object to the
application on that ground
the visit from the environmental health
officer observed no evidence of noise uh
noise breakout from the ancillary
building
and the noise management plan
regularizes the the outdoor play time
and provides respite each day for
residents
so um so in my submission to you there's
no ground to refuse the application on
the basis of the impact on residential
immunity through through noise
the second
issue which residents
raised was around highways and the local
highways authority are satisfied that
there's no significant
impact from the development the
circumstances are very different now to
those that existed in 1990 when a
planning inspector
dismissed an appeal and and referred to
highways as one of the grounds for that
the effect of of kobe on working
arrangements i know members will be
aware that has meant more people working
from home and it's meant more people
working less conventional working hours
so that does mean that drop-off and
pick-up times are likely to be more
staggered as well during the morning in
the afternoon than perhaps they've been
in the past
um i'd also like to commend the travel
plan which you know is very detailed and
clear and the efforts that have been
mentioned through the intensive scheme
to encourage more walking to the nursery
i know that parking and drop-offs are
always a concern for
residents who live near today in
nurseries because they're often in
residential areas but there's no
evidence of an unacceptable impact on
highway safety or a severe impact on the
road network which is the test that you
need to apply
as per the mppf
um
the latest objection from the neighbour
at number 10 also asks for
windows in the upper stories to be
obscured and it also asks for an
enclosed porch to be built to prevent
overlooking
and i'd refer members to the additional
information report which i think deals
with those suggestions well
it wouldn't be reasonable in my view to
impose planning conditions or controls
to that effect the building has been in
use for a nursery for some time and it
wouldn't be reasonable to impose
controls on that use
which were not required when previous
applications were improved
so in conclusion the application
complies in all relevant respects with
the core strategy the nursery is a real
asset to local parents carers and a key
part of the community
there's a recent letter of support from
irena chrimova on behalf of all the
parents that use the nursery and i think
that makes clear the the value they
attach to the nursery uh i hope members
have a chance to look at that on the
planning portal and we often talk at the
committee about the need to ensure
proper educational provision is made for
our children and that also applies to
day nurseries and the um responses make
clear there's a high demand for places
nursery places in this part of sale the
nursery has a waiting list which also
demonstrates that demand and the nursery
is offering care which is is good with
outstanding features so my view there's
a strong public interest in allowing
that use to continue
uh with a modest increase in numbers
um so to wrap up there's no valid
planning reason to refuse permission
and i encourage members to agree with
the officer's recommendation uh to grant
thank you
[Music]
thank you council hartley if you'd like
to return cc councillor gilbert
and you two have five minutes councillor
gilbert
thank you hi i'm shona gilbert i'm
councillor um in the same ward bastion
on mersey i'm here tonight representing
uh the four neighbouring properties four
six eight and ten
[Music]
oh
okay
um can you hear me better now thank you
um i'm here to represent the families in
the four neighbouring properties and i
was to be accompanied tonight by mr j
from uh 10 park avenue but unfortunately
one of his children is unwell so i'm
here um to speak on his behalf as well
um the residents would like me to stress
that they appreciate nurses nursery is
an important service and they would not
want to see the nursery closed i'm also
mindful that planning have recommended
to approve and explained away some of
their specific objections however i must
express my concerns that there are still
outstanding issues which will doubtless
have a negative
impact on local residents and the
quality of life while in their own home
i won't labor the points on uh regarding
inaccuracies in dates etc although the
residents do have much evidence to back
up their claims
i'll stick to the to the key points so
first it's noise the reports
simply do not reflect the reality of the
day-to-day life and the high levels of
noise that do affect the adjacent
properties i've heard multiple timed and
dated recordings from throughout the day
taken within those properties and it
supports their claims
it's also worth mentioning that the
residents had reported to me that things
were improving from may onwards and they
were really pleased with this
but when the recommendation to approve
was published last thursday um this has
immediately returned to previous noise
levels
and specifically the decision to have
the oldest children outside for the last
hour of the day really does make for
quite high noise levels and we would ask
that this practice is either ceased
moved to the main entrance or and taken
away from the garden gate or a porch
built to cancel out some of the noise
the next issue is traffic and highways
and
obviously we note that previous
applications were rejected on this basis
um looking at increasing the children
numbers to from 38 to 55
it seemed that this is explained through
an addition some additional parking
spaces and i'm just not sure i can
reconcile that with them with the
traffic issues that i've seen recordings
of and photographs of i appreciate we
can't police human behavior and there's
been some very questionable parking and
driving um on that road which i have
witnessed myself and surely this will
only get worse and put pedestrian
pedestrians including children at risk
as a governor of a local school with
some nursery spaces free i'm also
skeptical that there is such a dire need
within the borough
and i must note that
from anecdotal evidence from parents
whose children have been in the nursery
many of the parents do come from outside
of the borough
to conclude the increase in children
will have a detrimental impact on local
residents and we would request that
these concerns are considered in your
decision making tonight and we'd request
that if you do follow guidance and grant
permission to increase numbers that
strict conditions are put in place
regarding noise and the travel plan and
actively enforced because this has not
been our experience in the past thank
you
thank you council gilbert i'd like to
return to you see
um
mr dave would you like to comment on the
uh on the initial information report
when it talks about uh the resume at
number
10 or eight asking about
uh
frosted glass you know the more
protection at a bedroom window height
council heart we talked about it but it
isn't is in the additional information
report and officers do talk about that
could you just talk about that issue
uh i think
the relevant point is that the the
previous use of the
upper floors of the building was
residential use and and all those
windows served main habitable rooms so
um
there would already have been
the potential for overlooking from
the lawful
residential use of the property at that
time so
given that um
the the use that's proposed obviously is
more restricted in terms of um the hours
of occupation of the building
compared with a residential use which
would be occupied occupied 24 or
potentially occupied 24 hours
a day and and given that it it doesn't
appear reasonable to impose conditions
um
in relation to frosted glass
given that
there would potentially be less
overlooking than
than at the time well
than in relation to the previous lawful
use of the building
is everybody understanding that yeah
yep
council bunting
[Music]
thank you chairman um
i'm
more than happy with the recommendation
put forward
uh by the officers i've read the report
carefully i've been through all the uh
objections raised and i've listened to
the uh speaker council gilbert
um
as far as i can essentially be boiling
it down to the three issues of noise
parking and overlooking are you three
basic points in terms of the noise i
appreciate that during code
matters uh
measures had to be taken to try and
spread people out we can all argue about
the rights and the wrongs of covered but
that's not a matter that we're here to
discuss this evening
um and i appreciate that during that
period also maybe people with tempers
were afraid and people weren't happy
about restrictions being put in place
and that has also caused
uh
maybe people to be to be upset about the
noise generated uh but i am happy that
with the
current situation once we return to the
more normal way of working the noise
won't be an issue and now he's backed up
by the evidence that's been provided to
us in the report
i can't see any substantive argument
that would will sustain a refusal noise
grounds
also in terms of parking as has been
pointed out yes this is an aries has
parking issues but there are other other
uh
other causes as well as it can't just be
entirely uh put at the feet of the
nursery and industry has
made all best efforts to make sure that
they've done uh everything within their
power to try and mitigate as much of
their impact
as they possibly can plus as has been
pointed out with the changes to many
people's working arrangements it's far
more likely that you're going to get a
staggered arrangement in terms of
of parents uh
picking up and dropping off their
children than perhaps might previously
have been the case i think that's
something that will be
a fairly permanent change going forward
uh i don't think that people are racing
in to sort of do the nine to five people
of ex i think both people and employers
have recognized that there is a
substantial benefit to not doing that
and therefore that will be i think a
long-term impact rather than just a a
short-term one caused by the immediate
issues uh surrounding now so again uh i
can't agree um that uh there is uh that
there is a significant impact in terms
of parking from this change that would
be sufficient to warrant a refusal so
again i can't agree with the residents
objecting on that ground
and finally that brings me to the third
reason uh the overlooking as you have
just had the officer explain and that uh
council hartley mentioned in his uh in
his speech
again i think it would be wholly
unreasonable to insist upon uh foster
glass and what have you i don't think
that would be a
i think that would be in julianis and an
unreasonable request from this from this
planning committee therefore chairman
that means i've been through the three
possible reasons for refusal and i can't
support any of them ergo i have no
reason to refuse a and therefore i am uh
voting in favor of the officer
recommendation and i am more than happy
to propose that we accept officer
recommendation and grant thank you
chairman
very much council bonds and councillor
minis
[Music]
thank you chair um what was going to say
i'd like to thank danielle for
producing such a great uh nursery for
children clearly um and the a number of
the objections i actually
you know um don't agree um retrospective
nature of applications we do um
retrospective applications
um about the short ago about the need
for nurseries well places i think have
agreed that there are needs for
nurseries places and otherwise it
wouldn't be you know again if people
don't take their children there then
then then there won't be so many
children evidently there is a need so
they'll go there and the the the noisy
toys and musical instruments where
children make noise that's what they do
and i'm actually glad to hear that there
are there's musical instruments being
played um and i i hope that carries on
rather than stops um the actually long
hours i've i was really really impressed
with um i know how much of a nightmare
it is trying to get child care to fit
round your working hours and i think to
have such a long time means actually
people come and go at different times
some people pick their kids up earlier
some people pick them up later so that
it actually negates the traffic problem
but also it means it provides a more
flexible service for working parents so
i'll be i'm more than happy to second
the proposal to to grant this
application thank you
thank you council minister councillor
proctor please
thank you chair i completely disagree
only half an hour ago we rejected a
retrospective planning application
and this is another retrospective
planning application
the upper floors
of this nursery were residential
and
most people who live in a house go out
to work
so
don't
occupy their ground floor don't occupy
their first floor because they're out at
work and they come home in the evening
and if it's dark your curtains closed
so
the first floor and second floor were
the equivalent of a house
on the top
and now they're not
the
first floor has been changed into
nursery accommodation
with children and staff playing and
overlooking other people's gardens that
wouldn't have been before when it was
residential
also the previous application was for 38
children
not 55 which is
almost half as much again
so they've ignored their planning
application
that said
that when approved said they could have
38 children they've completely ignored
that
they've also changed a building in their
grounds
into extra nursery accommodation
that's not what it was before
how i don't understand how they could
decide to increase the number of
children
and use another floor of the property
without applying for planning permission
yet they have done
so i
really don't understand why we aren't
rejecting this
and i'll be voting against it thank you
thank you counselor proctor counselor
bunting like to come back
yes thank you chairman i'd just like to
just given the fact that i've always
spoken in favor of this i'd just like to
clarify one or two points in light of
the previous uh comments well first
obviously as you are well aware chairman
we deal with each individual application
on it so notice we can't cross compare
to the two secondly i would like to
point out that the previous application
as soon as it's been raised now uh the
fact it was retrospective in no way
impacted upon my reasons for uh
suggesting it should be refused and
voting in line with that it was not one
of the reasons i gave retrospective
applications occur we deal with
retrospective applications based on
their merits that which is in front of
us in the same version with any other
application so the faculty retrospective
per se
does not mean that i'm going to refuse
it i'm going to judge based
based on what's in front of me based on
the application this is being applied
for and not based on the fact that it is
a retrospective so simply given those
comments i simply wish to come back and
explain my position in relation to that
i accept it's retrospective but i am
viewing it in terms of the application
in front of us in the way that we are
required so to do thank you jen
okay thanks for council bunsen
councillor thomas please thank you chair
um i'm minded the same way as council
products are to be to be fair uh we get
to report in front of us whether it's
retrospective or not we have information
within that report that allows us to
to be guided
um we've had two historical applications
one for 141 for 30 children as an
increase and both of them we were
rejected one went to appeal but on the
grounds of public and highway safety
to the residents of residential
amenities of the occupiers and
properties on park avenue in particular
because the vehicle activity generated
by the use would be necessary and
incidental to the operation of a day
nursery and would exacerbate the
existing parking and maneuvering
problems in their area
this in no way will relieve that or
alleviate it
and until you blue in the face people
take their children to nurseries between
eight and nine o'clock generally and
pick them up between five and six
o'clock again generally and we're asking
them to take more cars in fact we're not
asking them to take more cars because
they're already at 55
is the concern is that if we give them
planning permission for 55 will it be 65
in the in the near future
i'm also a little bit disappointed that
if you have a disabled child you can
only use the ground floor because
there's no access to basement and there
is no access to the top floor because a
lot of lift was mentioned it had not
been put forward
um
we also have to take into consideration
those that are affected by this the
residents
and there are plenty of them
i'm not sure well some members have in
the past when we've discussed it said oh
there are letters from all over the
place if the people that live in one was
from tip street if they live in tip
street and work in sale it's perfectly
natural for them to use a nursery and
sale that isn't the issue the issue is
the people that live on par road at park
avenue
there is already a planning a parking
issue there is already a traffic issue
and we're asking we're looking to get
permission so i i
can't do that because it's children
and if you look at
the road
the road has parking to the opposite
side bay parking to the opposite side
there are some h's which i know aren't
legally
no parking but our hatches have been
paid for by residents to stop people
parking from to their drive
so on the grounds of parking
on the grounds of los angeles due to
traffic on the road
noise
that's a tenuous thing it depends when
the environmental study was done
at what time but if you're putting
children
out at
four o'clock in the afternoon and their
older children they're more likely to
make a noise and as the residents were
probably there before it was a nursery
then i would say there's a precedent to
to manage that
so
on them on the grounds of parking
grounds a lot of mini i mean
i propose that we reject the officer's
recommendation
thank you councillor thomas and
jeff could you talk about highways and
the parking situation
[Music]
yeah
excuse me uh yeah in terms of um the
proposal um we didn't um with the travel
plan and the measures they're proposing
we didn't see that we could sustain an
argument um
the surrounding streets are protected
um
and yes we can't control where people
park
but we didn't think we could sustain a
refusal on the increase in the the
numbers of um pupils who would be
attending the nursery and that's the
reason for our
recommendation
can i just say um
mr evanson
um
do you think you don't feel as there's a
danger to to pedestrians someone talks
about danger to pedestrians children and
people passing by we don't feel there's
a danger caused by the extra numbers and
the traffic it will attract
in terms of the numbers and the extra
traffic it would attract we didn't feel
it would
but we are also mindful that people
probably park
incorrectly using the junctions and such
likes but that probably takes place
currently in any event particularly with
some of the comments which have already
been done but we can't really we can't
really control that we have got measures
in place
protecting junctions protecting um
adjacent um
site accesses in terms of people's
drives
um
but we can't we can't control how that
works and when i've dealt with nurseries
previously
a lot of the times inspectors see that
there's restrictions on the on the on
the road and therefore
you know how how what else can you
actually do so therefore if you're going
to argue at the case of objecting to a
plan application
in this particular instance
then you you need to be able to justify
that it's going to be an intensification
and the applicant has tried to take
measures
where they are encouraging people to use
alternatives a lot of the street is
has got restrictions on
there's a number of areas where the um
junctions are protected
um but unfortunately as members know we
we can't control how people want to stop
whether it be the middle of the road
sometimes or or on um double yellow
lines or on junctions we can't we can't
control how that goes on but the road is
protected so
assuming everyone uses the road as they
should do
and therefore doesn't cause obstructions
and doesn't stop or park where they
ask not to or
restrictions are in place then i don't
see that the increase would would be a
problem but potentially if someone has
blocked the road
is parking in inconsiderately then there
could potentially be an issue with with
parents walking down that road but one
would hope that people would have dear
to the restrictions which
are actually currently on the ground
with that counselor i canola please
i just wanted to clarify because i
missed the very beginning of the office
of speaking but i've been here for the
rest of the deliberations am i able to
vote or not
you're fine counsellor yeah
thank you chad just just threw you
through yourself
chair to the traffic officer
the number of vehicles on the road has
grown exponentially since 2007. in 2007
this council said that
the
parking and the traffic to the road
was
not manageable enough to allow
granting go up to 40 people
notwithstanding the fact that as i say
the exponential growth not only of
traffic on the umpire road but the
number of cars that the residents on
park road will park how many would
would have
also increasing
how can we not
say that by allowing more cars to be
stopping adjacent whether it be on the
corner
whether it be on york road
uh close to the nursery that is not
going to impact on safety from of the
children going to the nursery
of
people walking past pedestrians whether
it be old or young walking down the road
by that
and
as a matter of
that the lack of
respect that a lot of drivers have you
can go around
probably most nurseries any school
and see some absolutely abort parking
anywhere in the borough so we're saying
that
although
two previous applications you've refused
on the objections are very valid
and very personal to the people who live
on par road
but
now because it's what people do it
doesn't mitigate danger
i'm sorry i think that he does
i think that we have to control
how many cars pull up outside
properties that i use with children
involved
thank you councillor thomas would you
like to respond sermonson
thank you um yeah i think i think in
2007
um
the planning proposals the policies have
significantly changed
um and where we currently sit is what
what we have to judge and what's in
front of us
and we have to be able to demonstrate
that there's a significant
harm danger in terms of um the increase
in in those num pupil numbers
and that's why it's based on on that
we're not dismissing what has previously
gone
and it is a discussion we did have
around the application when we were in
the office
but things have significantly changed
since 2007
and we have to judge
the application based on the policies
which we we currently work with within
and that's why we've recommended the
approval of the planning application
[Music]
miss coley's going to make give us a
comment miss carly
thank you thank you chet also just to
say in planning terms
this committee has to assume that people
will behave properly so if there's
sufficient parking on site for that to
work appropriately for the numbers of
children if parents choose not to use
that and park antisocially that's not
something you can take into account is
this parking
enough for this for this use and if not
would it have a severe impact on the
highway network not
yes there's enough parking but parents
won't use it and there's already traffic
problems in the area
unfortunately doesn't stack up in
planning terms although i understand why
the point is made
i think only thing
that i would say is that
referring back to what the position is
in 2007 would not be a material planning
consideration in respect of the
application before the committee today
the position has changed dramatically
and i think one of the issues is that
for instance now there is a travel plan
which there probably wasn't in 2007.
councillor thomas
thank you just coming up with miss coley
but
by increasing the numbers
rather than being a parking issue is a
lot of amenity for people
using um
using the road to dump cars wherever
they would and also if there's only nine
spaces 55 children it won't go into nine
cars so there's not enough car parking
so but in just and
that's just my my opinion my opinion on
that and regarding
the the historical
i wasn't trying to say that it was what
i was using was that we refused them in
them years
exponentially the number of cars on the
road and the number of cars owned by
individual households have grown
a lot more than we would have expected
from them so i'm just saying that
taking today
as a as a reference
there are more cars on the road and more
people own cars so there would be a
bigger problem that's why i've gotta i'm
coming against not using to
thank you councillor thomas just we've
got a number of people who want to speak
just ask y'all to be patient councillor
maitland first please
thanks chair
um i've worked in nurseries and day
nurseries and children's centres for a
very very long time before i retired
you do not get everyone arriving at the
same time
at all
it's it's literally from what whenever
they open seven o'clock maybe half seven
till the end of the day it really is
spaced out i can't see it being a
problem
thank you councillor maitland councillor
was in please
you can hear me now
um she said most of the staff will be
walking
to the to the to the uh to the nursery
and at least 75 families live within the
area so it means they'll be walking to
the school to dropping the kids also
bear in mind everybody please
but trafford already struggling for the
school places
and i think uh
these nurseries are playing a dominant
role to accommodate most and most
children to the schools number three
and she has already mentioned and it is
all written here
that outdoor activities will be mitigate
because they were playing the children
were playing outside because of the
covert now they are trying to reduce
this and it is everybody is trying to
use this everywhere and no musical
activities will be run
side
i don't think there is any problem and i
fully support this application
thank you
thank you councillor hassan council
minister please
that's a couple of points i mean
councilman made one about the fact that
it's not going to be everyone drops off
but like you said between eight and nine
and and picks up between five and six
this is not true i picked up my youngest
when he was at nursery at 4 30 so that's
not between five and six so you know um
and i didn't drop off at the times that
you specify either so and that but you
know it's i think
we need to have a realistic
understanding um
of you know yes there's going to be some
noise it's a nursery and it has been
nurtured for a long time when we're
saying that number of the cars are going
up from they've gone up since like you
know when i was a kid but like in since
2007 how they really are households
having way more cars i'm seeing actually
a drop off in more recent years the
people are starting to go down the one
car road families with one cars rather
than one car rather than two i'm seeing
increasing number of those so i don't
think they're necessarily i think you
know from 2007 i don't think there's
masses more um not everybody drives
their kid to school that's not that's
not what they do i never drove my kids
to nurseries at all um i took them on
the tram and they were commuting
children that's what they were then they
went to the nursery that was where my
place of work was at the hospital so you
know if we can not
generalize and decide what people are
apparently going to do
and understand that actually people's
lives are all very different some people
work from home some people don't work
from home somehow people have a mixture
of these days it's varying and there's
obviously a demand for it otherwise it
wouldn't be there it's been there for a
long time it's not like it's not been a
nursery and it's just suddenly now
becoming a nursery and there's suddenly
all this noise and whatnot kids are
going to play outside there's going to
be some noise i'm glad that the kids are
going to play outside so they should go
outside right you know the musical
things will be limited to indoors we
can't this is you know
we're going down some sort of madness
idea of going oh you know
kids create noise of course they do this
nursery and the kids kids play and
people are going to pick them up at
different times and drop them in
different times let's all have you know
some sense of realism
and you know understand
what what you know how having young
children is thank you
thank you council minister councillor
bunting
thank you chairman points have been made
already thank you
thank you councillor proctor
thank you chair
i'd missed one of um councillor thomas's
points and
when he made it i re-read the document
i'm appalled that
um
a small child with a mobility impairment
can only use the ground floor or the
outbuilding
that's
unfair
and i'd class that as direct
discrimination
against that child
and
that adds to
my view i will be voting against this
thank you
thank you councillor procter
mr dave would you like to comment on
that that issue that council proctor has
raised
um
i mean again under under our current um
planning policies um
you know i don't think that's
something that um we could sustain a
refusal on um
[Music]
i mean i suppose you know obviously
we've had the previous up application um
for a nursery in parkington a few months
ago where the committee did decide to
put a condition on
regarding a stairlift so i suppose that
is an option
to the committee if
if they wanted to go down that route but
um i don't think a refusal based on on
that reason would be something that we
could sustain at appeal
so yeah we obviously
as set out in the report we asked the
question about
a lift but um
you know as
as a sir in the report the applicant
didn't feel that was
something that was appropriate in this
case
thank you chair
and that was a residential home
that was for three children with autism
and we put that condition in
this is a place where 55 children go
if we saw fit to put that as a condition
for
a home that only had three children in
it
i don't understand
why it's okay
for
a place that has 55 children in it
instead of the 38 it's got planning
approval for
can get away with that could anyone
advise me please
mr day yeah
so yeah the application that i was
talking about was a
nursery in
the englewood nursery in partington um
i can't remember the numbers of
children
now but it
it
yeah it wasn't it wasn't the one for
three
yeah it wasn't as many as 50 but it was
something in the region of 20 or 30 yeah
i'm going to ask our legal officer to
come in counselor promoter
the chairs indicating that he couldn't
hear that could you uh repeat with a
microphone
[Music]
uh
yes um
well
the equality is
i was looking at crossing uh various
applications
if actually one looks at page 74
and
75 i think
the uh
report uh
properly and deals with the issues of
equalities as in fact have all the
applications tonight i think those
matters that council has had regard to
are properly dealt with
and are part of the basis for the uh
recommendation that this application be
approved
okay thanks for that um
i'll uh just make my comments um
i know this site actually quite well
because i have to pass by going to the
the local gym would you believe and uh
when i pass by i i can hear children
playing there and i cannot well
understand the neighbors being disturbed
by that
perhaps i wouldn't like it
but it has been a nursery for 14 years
that's not suddenly happened
and i have to say to everybody there is
ample parking in that area there's lots
of spaces
and i don't believe we're going to have
the uh
the danger frankly what people talked
about when all these cows turn up let's
drop the children up there's a travel
plan in place and i'm
very happy with the travel plan it's a
it's a brave one
um 75 of the children to be walking to
school
that is wonderful i wish our schools
were like that
i don't
if i lived there i'm i'm sure i'd be
disturbed but by the children
but i don't think those issues are so
significant to turn on this application
you know
we've moved on it's 14 years that this
this site has been used as a nursery
and
i don't believe the issues at the rays
are so significant that we can turn them
down because it's problematic
for people but not so significant to
turn it down
um
i'll be supporting the application
um i don't know
has it been moving seconded that we
support the application it has has
already been done
and it's been moved and seconded that
we've refused the application
does any other members wish to speak
briefly we have discussed this at some
length
no
counselor maitland
thanks chair just just quickly i think
making the whole nursery as councillor
proctor said making more be more
accessible to children to all children
would be favorable
and could that be put as a condition in
is it
i think i think we're revisiting an
issue that's been dealt with councillor
maitland with respect
we've dealt with that issue
it's fine no no you're fine so let's
we'll take the
we'll take the refusal first be moving
second that we refuse this application
all those in favor of refusal please
show
that's two hands down all those in favor
of the application please show
favorite
against refusal against refusal yeah
against refusal yeah
okay hands down
any abstentions to that
no
okay
so that's been lost that proposal to
refuse has been lost we'll now take
a vote on the proposal to grant the
application all those in favor of
granting the application please show
okay
hands down and those against granting
the application that's two
hands down and any abstentions to that
vote no
so the application has been granted
everybody thank you for a very good
discussion
and
thank you for allowing me to share chair
thank you everyone uh thank you to
councillor walsh for
sharing that item uh much appreciated we
will move on to the
last application uh for approval now
which is uh moreland's junior school
application 107787
and we'll start with an introduction
from ms milner thank you
thank you chair
this application site comprises a school
and associated playing field set within
sale more within a predominantly
residential area the playing fields are
designated as protected open space the
existing school is a two-form entry and
supports 10 classrooms
the application seeks planning
permission for a single-story extension
of the school along the broad road
frontage the school and so the works
would include the provision of four
additional classrooms to create a
three-form entry school
additional works include the extension
of the existing parking area increasing
number of parking spaces from six to
fourteen and this will include
accessible spaces and an electric
vehicle charging point
an existing multi-use games area or muga
shall be relocated within the school
grounds and there are also associated
landscape works
vehicle access shall remain from broad
street
the application is reported to committee
because the school is a local authority
school and representations have been
received contrary to officer
recommendation
these represent representations
predominantly cite the impact on parking
and potential for overstills parking
within the surrounding area in addition
to concerns on design drainage impact
from construction a lack of local
engagement and a lack of policy
compliant
these concerns have been duly noted and
considered however the increase in
parking
on site is considered to be appropriate
given the scalar development and the
local highway authority have raised no
objection as detailed within the
additional information report fair
consideration to the cycle parking
provision
um has been taken and an additional
condition is proposed to increase the
amount of on-site cycle parking in
addition to the scooter parking area and
we're also proposing a travel plan
condition
sport england have also raised no
objection to this development and the
site would remain capable of providing
two full-size grass-playing pitches and
matters relating to design residential
amenity drainage air quality and entries
are all considered to be acceptable by
officers therefore subject to conditions
we do recommend approval thank you chair
thank you miss milner um there are no
speakers for against this uh item
um
i had i had one question actually
relating to the additional information
report and the
cycle parking provision
um
which was a concern of mark well
probably my only concern actually with
the application um
and and the lack of the travel plan um
which i know has been suggested in the
conditions so
um am i am i understanding it correctly
that the condition
will require 20 sheffield stands
um but it then refers to 30
bicycle parking so wouldn't 20 stands
mean 40 spaces just wouldn't be
clarified
so you know there's going to be an
addition so there's 10 there's five
additional there's five existing so it's
ten existing cycle parking spaces
they're going to be reprovided
by five sheffield stands which is ten
spaces and then we're going to request
an additional ten sheffield stands to
provide an additional 20 cycle spaces so
there's a total of 30
and then there'll be 40 scooter parking
um although this is a slight shortfall
on sbd3 in regards to cycle parking
given that it's a primary school that is
more of a demand for scooter parking
than cycle parking but our spd3 i think
was written prior to that demand
thank you that's helpful um
any members looking to speak on this
item counselor minis
the school clearly needs to expand
because it's going from two form to
three form so entry so it needs to get
bigger anyway i think that um
you know therefore it has six the number
of classrooms it has to expand i
completely i like the fact that that's
been considered about how this how
primary school children actually travel
in they tend to scoot more than they
cycle in so yes that's probably what
more focus on on the exclusive spaces
but yeah i'm happy to propose that we um
support this application to grant it
thank you
thank you uh councillor bunting
nothing really to add chairman i'll
simply second that which has just been
said thank you
thank you councillor chalking
uh thank you um
just to add to the so what's being said
um i like it it's a really good design
there's a lot of thought that's gone
into it um it's sympathetic to the
existing building
i i acknowledge the um concerns of
residents
that's always going to be the case when
the school starts to expand it does need
it just like to add i particularly like
the inclusion of the special education
needs room it's so needed in the borough
and um
we need we need to increase that space
so all and authors aren't happy to vote
for this
thank you councillor chalking any other
members looking to speak councillor
welton uh just a quick question that
didn't seem to be anything about these
you know sort of the
environmental impact of the building or
what's being done to mitigate that in
the report i presume obviously they
don't have to meet the relevant
standards so is that implicit or have i
just missed something
in regards to um biodiversity we are
asking for additional burden back boxes
um to assist with that and electric
vehicle charging points if that's what
you're referring to
more to do with the fabric of the
building itself and
you know what
energy efficiency and that kind of
so much of um what you previously known
as brian has moved into building rugs so
that will be dealt with through the
building rogues application also um it
does not report that there has been
suggestions of an air source heat pump
but that hasn't been included within
this application and we specifically
reference that that would would need to
form part of a separate application
because that has uh separate issues and
would include the entire school i assume
[Music]
thank you ms miller thank you council so
well 1080 members can say well
thanks chair um
we are approving um
[Music]
this skill from a two-form entry to a
three-form entry that's 120
extra pupils and it's certainly going to
happen that we were talking about
highways earlier
it's certainly going to have an effect
on the highways and uh
our highways officers are i wouldn't say
they were happy but they don't see
strong reasons for to refuse the grounds
for reviews on this
i would just say to the residents
i would say thank you for for for what
you've done i think you you've been very
reasonable
you know
a school having an extra classroom
installed 120 extra pupils is going to
be a big change um if there are issues
please report them to us but i'd like to
thank the residents of the of temple
road for the patience thank you chad
thank you councillor walsh any other
speakers looking to speak on this
no i i mean i'd probably like to return
to the issue that i mentioned in my
question actually i think there's a lot
that's really good about the application
and i'm generally in favor um i welcome
the
additional information that there's
going to be more
cycle parking spaces
i do still think that's a significant
shortfall though um
i think the gardens requires
uh over 130 and we're now providing you
know providing 30.
um
and
i don't think the
the report is completely accurate on
this because it it does talk about
primary school-aged children being 4-11
but this is a junior school so it will
be a higher range range still i mean i
still agree that you know it might be
that a lot of those children wouldn't
cycle to school but i think we should be
aspiring for some of them to do so for
older children to do so and
the reason i still have a reservation
about it is the lack of a travel plan
which is disappointing and i know
there's a condition to submit one
but that travel plan
is gonna have to
uh aim to reduce the number of
children being driven to that school and
that's a big concern of residents to
parking and um so that's the only way
that you will reduce the the
the the number of cars going to that
school
um if you can walk to the school then
you'd like to think people would walk so
i think to get that modal shift
um another report talks about
the stands that are there are not used
well
that that might be right and there might
be a number of reasons for that but to
provide that modal shift that we need to
see towards actual travel i think you've
got to provide the facilities um
so i had him i had in mind suggesting an
amendment to that condition of around 40
spaces but i'm not sure i'll move that
given that we've got 30.
um
but i would
you know i would like to think the
school would be ambitious in their
travel plan and that they'll be open
minded to
installing more cycle parking spaces
because it's no good
generating the demand if there isn't the
supply so that's the reservation i have
um
but i don't think that's sufficient to
refuse permission because i think in all
other respects um it's it's a good
scheme
ms milner is going to just clarify
something thank you
just to clarify a junior school is still
up to 11. um it's infants and juniors
and they go from four to eleven it's
secondary when they become older than
11. so it would deal with the younger
children but notwithstanding that and
the cycle park and provision we can only
look at the extension we can't address
the existing school as a whole so i
think the to be policy compliant for the
um in terms of sbd4 sorry three we need
to provide 42 um cycle spaces that
includes the 120 additional children and
the nine additional staff it works out
um
but we're proposing
um
70 spaces but i do appreciate that 40 of
them are scooter spaces um but in terms
of the school as a whole there is a
shortfall and that is acknowledged
i do apologize if the report is not
clear on that point
thank you
yeah my point about the edge of the
children was it's it's a junior school
there are no infants so it's up to 11
but it'll only start at seven so you
haven't got any infants at school um so
that that was my the age range talks
about four to 11 year olds which isn't
which isn't right um
on the cycle parking i'd just like to
return to that ever may because there
was reference in the report to 130
spaces being being what was required um
and if that's if that's not right that's
not right but i'm sure i've got that
from somewhere
thank you
uh miss kelly
yeah so the the reference to spd3 there
that's uh unfortunately it's an error
that's looking at the school as a whole
so we've gone back and looked at the
specific needs of the extension
right i see okay that that makes sense
okay
uh
i'm happy to leave that issue there
unless any other members feel strongly
but i i
i do think we need to be more ambitious
in in providing facilities if we want to
see that model shift so i'll leave it
with that comment any other members
looking to speak on this item
no uh it has been moved and seconded
that we
approved planning permission in
accordance with the office
recommendation so we'll vote on that
motion now so all those in favor of
approval if you could raise your hands
and that is unanimous thank you
everybody
and that brings us to the end of uh item
six on the
applications to develop
[Music]
uh
any urgent business to cover
i'd like to talk about outcomes
so there's no urgent business we
considered the exclusion resolution
earlier and
item nine we considered the part to
report earlier on so
if members could remain behind just to
uh
have some information from miss kohli
but at that point i'll declare a meeting
closed thank you